Vermont senator and Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
says healthcare is a human right not a
privilege
he is unveiling the latest version of
his plan to get rid of private health
care insurance and had the government
foot the bill estimated to cost roughly
thirty five trillion dollars over ten
years Republicans love the proposal as
an election season weapon against
Democrats some of whom are not that
thrilled about it here is correspondent
Peter Doocy
how much of a trendsetter is Bernie
Sanders he's now got primary opponents
nodding along with him please do not
tell us that this is a rational health
care system Kirsten Gillibrand later
took the mic herself this has to become
the next social safety net it has to
become something that is there for you
no matter what no matter if you can
afford it no matter where you live no
matter what and she's not the only one
Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris and Cory
Booker are also running for president
using the new Sanders sponsored
medicare-for-all as part of their
platforms the American people wants and
we are going to deliver a Medicare for
All single-payer system but candidate
Amy Klobuchar is unconvinced this is a
strong idea out there but I've made
clear what I think I'd like to do to get
us to universal health care and that is
to first of all put in a public option
Medicare for all would mean nobody pays
premium or a deductible and everybody is
put under the government's care this
would mean adding a hundred and eighty
million people to the Medicare program
and with the government takeover we can
see from other countries that we're
going to have long wait times and
rationing of health care any questions
this total transformation of health care
would also wipe out private insurance
companies on their Medicare for all we
cover all basic health care needs so
they're not going to be there to do that
I suppose if you want to make yourself
look a little bit more beautiful you
want to work on that nose areas they can
do that
basically BlueCross BlueShield would be
reduced to nose jobs something like that
so this is the one jobs plan that just
refers to nose jobs and in the coming
days we should find out whether or not
medicare-for-all has more support in the
Senate than the climate change
addressing green new deal which received
zero votes Brett let's talk about all of
that Peter thank you